it's fashion week has just come to an
end and you may have noticed more
diversity on the runway and beyond
that's because a once uniform idea of
beauty is now being redefined models
that look more like actual consumers are
gracing the pages of magazines catalogs
and websites and that includes men and
women with scars stretch marks even
physical disabilities I sat down with
some industry leaders to discuss this
changing face of fashion I am so tempted
to just go straight to the name because
the name says it all says it all I was
meant to be a nari model and she says
posing for arey one of the nation's top
lingerie brands fulfilled her childhood
ambition I remember coming in New York
when I was a little girl looking up at
the billboards and being like one day I
want to be on that film you said that I
said that that backbone a necessity for
an adopted child born in India and
raised in West Virginia living with
polio I have two scars on my hips I have
scars on my legs I've scarred my ankle
flipping through magazines and seeing
these models that were it had no
imperfections and feeling like well
where do I belong she found the answer
in 2014 with the Aerie real campaign
which abandoned photoshopping its models
today global brand president Jennifer
Foyle says their even bolder Airy real
has the opportunity to show every woman
who she is what she represents whether
she has a disability or maybe she has a
passion what about that maybe she has a
drive a mission a cause we'd like to
represent that too our role models
Express that 100%
Harry received thousands of video
submissions just a second much better I
feel like women like me are often not
the image that's in a fraud campaign
marketing vice president Stacy McCormick
says former customers have now become
the changing face of the industry I see
tattooed girls I've seen mommies who had
babies of course we see yes didn't I go
yeah woman of a certain age you know
diversity and race and ethnicity and
this young woman that's Chelsea Warner
she submitted her video an absolutely
amazing video and she is a gymnast and
absolutely loves Aly Raisman you should
have seen the union of those two women
but it was the beauty of a role model
and someone that really looks up to her
[Music]
it all comes down to the dollars and
cents retail analyst Marshall Cowan says
marketers have caught up with the real
world competition has heated up in
almost every industry you see less
businesses competing for the same
dollars we're trying to capture the
attention of very specific audiences and
with great value the recession of 2008
and 9 was something that really caused
businesses to step back and say oh we
need to rethink the equation we need to
find growth in any corner we can find it
so it force them to be more creative
exactly right that includes the men's
department to Mickey on Burrell is CEO
of the popular men's brand bonobos we
saw 3x the amount of traffic we've seen
strong growth double-digit growth in our
business we've continued to see that we
continue to see that accelerate since
zero campaign yeah just the summer yep
because what we have seen is that we put
ourselves on the map we're saying that
we believe that it takes all sorts so
whether it's about you know your sexual
identity whether it's about the way you
dress whether it's about your body shape
your race whatever it is that we should
essentially all be accepting and
inclusive of many many definitions of
what it means to be a man we featured
the series of guys this is Leila Melvin
who had this really interesting path
from NFL player to astronaut and now it
does a lot of work with girls around
STEM education right here and in Africa
this is Chris Moshe who was the first
transgender athletes make the u.s.
national team and more retailers have
joined the bandwagon
j.crew relaunched its brand late last
year to introduce larger clothing sizes
third love embraces an aging woman in
every form and stage of her life we're
not at a point today where we're going
backwards this is a point where we're
going forwards and going forwards with
gusto and some retailers say what
started as a business venture is quickly
becoming a social responsibility
intimate apparel a brand can change the
world last summer I was on a ferryboat
and this mom came over to me and she
said my daughter has an insulin patch
thank you now my daughter goes out
wearing a bathing suit proudly and and
these little moments to me and touching
one person at a time
has become just a mission of mine I
think we all saw that it was the Dove
real beauty campaign that sort of
launched this back in 2006 the next big
thing we're told is this marketing of
the same product to different groups
like an anti-aging cream that you would
market to like and someone who's older
as well as someone who's younger so it's
sort of giving opening up the markets so
that a lot more people it's only me that
it actually took this long to happen
because it makes so much sense but I
think I mean I think everybody everybody
wants to be seen in the first place you
want to be seen as in the advertising
that's speaking to you in teaching
everybody to love themselves as they are
the first is trying to be something
that's unattainable